[Music]
i want to talk about some interesting
things related to
vitamin c
so the first question is
is ascorbic acid
vitamin c well according to the
dictionary it is but there's an
interesting change in the dictionary
apparently in the older dictionaries
which i have quite a few different
dictionaries
the definition of vitamin c is
non-ascorbic acid that was actually
updated later in the dictionaries so if
you're reading a recent edition of a
dictionary you're going to find that
vitamin c is ascorbic acid but is it
really does the type of ascorbic acid
sold in vitamins nowadays
is that
very similar to the vitamin c that is in
nature well what you need to know is
this 80 of all the ascorbic acids sold
in the world comes from china and the
rest of it is manufactured by
mainly two other chemical companies and
they make it from glucose from sugar and
other chemicals sometimes they'll use
sulfuric acid
and the sugar usually comes from corn so
is it possible that this manufactured
chemical
can be the same as the vitamin c you
would get in nature in my opinion it is
not the same it's actually very
different now would i personally ever
take a synthetic ascorbic acid in a
certain dosage well maybe for a detox
cleanse
but definitely not as a routine thing
but this video is about increasing your
awareness
on the type of vitamin c that you're
probably might be taking and just so you
have all the data because when someone
tells you that there's no difference
between synthetic ascorbic acid and
vitamin c they're both the same thing
well actually that's not 100 true i'm
going to put this research right down
below you can check it out
some real interesting data on vitamin c
as far as the research and the
conclusion of a lot of the randomized
controlled trials is that there is
little to no benefit from taking high
doses of ascorbic acid there's some
mixed results with
lessening the side effects from cancer
but there is a lot of misinterpretation
and again i'm going to put that data
down below you should check it out so
the research on colds
cancer
heart benefits mortality sports
performance it's a very very minimal if
zero benefit now i think regarding colds
the reason why it may help you is
because ascorbic acid is
acidic and i do know that taking an acid
tends to
put the phagocytes in high gear it makes
them work faster and the phagocytes are
part of the immune system that help
tends to clean up everything but you can
do the same thing with apple cider
vinegar why would you need to take
ascorbic acid so number one little to no
benefit
number two most the vitamin c sold out
there is fake and i'm talking about
synthetic of just one part of the
vitamin c complex that comes if we
compare this to nature if we look in
nature vitamin c comes in a complex with
different parts you have the antioxidant
part which is the ascorbic acid you have
you have other parts like about
flavonoids you have
the j factor which helps with oxygen you
have you have vitamin k which is part of
that complex which helps decrease
bleeding and you also have copper in a
certain enzyme form because most vitamin
complexes come with a mineral but the
point is that in nature you have many
many other
parts of the vitamin c complex not to
mention
all the phytonutrients and
the plant-based chemicals that we
haven't even discovered yet as well
we're constantly discovering new
phytonutrients that come with different
vitamins and minerals so if you were to
look at maybe the top 10
sold vitamin c supplements on amazon and
look in the back of the label you're
going to notice that
they all say ascorbic acid but they
might add a pinch of rose hips you know
but
they're based on ascorbic acid in large
quantities either 500 milligrams to a
thousand or two thousand milligrams per
serving size now a normal rda would be
like something like 70 or 80
milligrams okay
but you're getting 500 to over a
thousand milligrams of the synthetic
version of a part of the whole vitamin c
complex now this type of vitamin c is
very very inexpensive it's very very
cheap and this is why when you buy
synthetic vitamin c it's going to be
like might be five
seven ten dollars for a whole bottle
well that's because the ingredients so
when you get a vitamin it's very very
important to read the label
to make sure that it's not synthetic now
of course i'm not biased of my vitamin c
but i wanted to point out
two things number one does it come from
real food is it a vitamin complex and
does it actually list the type of food
that's on there does it come from
blueberries acerola berry strawberry etc
and then what form does it come in is it
freeze dried is it organic or is it just
conventional these are all important
factors because the thing about vitamin
c is that
it's destroyed with heat
and light and so this is why when you
drink orange juice that's been
pasteurized cooked
you're getting very little vitamin c
unless they add the ascorbic acid back
in it as a preservative the best type of
vitamin c that you can get is from food
or food based vitamins and the food that
has the highest vitamin c are going to
be leafy greens it could be in the
berries it can also be in lemons as well
as their peel but you can also get
vitamin c from organ meats
liver
kidney
adrenal glands
even brain but the problem is a lot of
people don't like organ meats but then
again a lot of people don't like
vegetables too
so there's a couple foods that are
really really high in vitamin c peppers
sauerkraut but if you're gonna buy a
very cheap vitamin c supplement realize
what you're really getting is you're
just getting plain ascorbic acid which
is made chemically from corn and
sulfuric acid now another point i want
to bring up about vitamin c is that
it doesn't really get absorbed that well
if you're consuming sugar at the same
time so if your vitamin c is a trouble
and it has sugar in it like fructose or
glucose or high fructose corn syrup or
maltodextrin
which by the way
many times the way that they uh dry this
ascorbic acid out in the chemical
companies
is they use a spray agent called
maltodextrin so we're adding this
ascorbic acid with maltodextrin which is
a sugar and that's going to impair the
absorption of vitamin c now why
well it's because the chemistry of
vitamin c is very very similar to the
chemistry of glucose and so if the body
has a chance
it's always going to go after the
glucose first before the vitamin c so if
you're taking some refined carbs or
sugar at the same time you're taking
vitamin c you're not going to absorb it
and see now the next point i want to
bring up is if someone's using a mega
dose of ascorbic acid and they're using
it as an antioxidant
there's some interesting data that
this so-called antioxidant turns into a
pro-oxidant it creates more oxidation
and that really has to do with
antioxidants in nature always come as a
network
not as an individual antioxidant so as
soon as this antioxidant donates its
electron
now it becomes unstable it becomes a
free radical but scorpic acid a lot of
times will give you diarrhea bloating
and it can even act as a pro-oxidant not
as an antioxidant so in summary it's
best to get your vitamin c from actual
food or food-based vitamins
not the synthetic version
of a
part of the vitamin c complex
unless you're doing maybe a short-term
cleanse but you don't want to take it on
a long-term basis now if you haven't
seen my video on what vitamin c actually
does
i put it up right here check it out